several people have tweeted me the same
thing Judy did earlier this week at Dave
Ramsey calm is the Twitter account by
the way or at Dave Ramsey rather can you
discuss the 529 expansion to cover K
through 12 to ition now your 529 savings
plan is an after-tax dollar you already
pay taxes on it like a Roth is that goes
into an account and it grows tax-free
for college until the new tax law kicks
in and the new tax law now says it grows
tax-free for college or K through 12
which is pretty neat if you wanted to
pull it out to pay for private school in
other words you can so the school choice
advocates are going bananas and saying
this is a big victory and so forth but
basically that's what it comes down to
is that and the other thing that's going
to allow you to do is roll an ESA to a
529 and I guess vice versa I'm not sure
but you rolled your si you know if I've
29 should you want to there's really no
advantage to that here's the thing on
the K through 12 it's a nice thing
okay it's a nice feature and the
tax-free growth is in there let's say
you put in ten thousand dollars and it
grows 20 percent that's $2,000 no taxes
on the $2,000 growth taxes on the $2,000
growth in the twenty five percent tax
brackets five hundred bucks okay so if
you're saving for kindergarten through
sixth grade the amount that's in your
account that is growth is very small and
the amount of tax savings is very small
so the mathematical facts are you know
maybe for senior high school maybe high
school private high school it might you
know it might actually work out to
bother and do this with a 529 but I mean
if you got a five year old and you're
gonna throw money in a 529 to send them
to private school next year it does
absolutely no good because only the
growth is grow
tax-free I mean only the growth is
tax-free you didn't save any money by
putting money in there it's only the
growth and it's it's a and the growth
only matters over a long period of time
so when you're saving for a brand new
baby for college you got 18 years of
growth that's tax-free now we're talking
about some money I mean you might have
ninety a hundred thousand dollars for
the growth and so you might save thirty
thousand dollars on taxes using a 529
and so we do recommend the right kinds
of 529s and/or ESA s or those kinds of
things educational savings account works
the same way but if you're saving it for
three years it's not gonna be enough
growth to have enough tax savings to
even it's not it doesn't matter much so
it's more something like a lot of stuff
out of Washington it's more about the
chest-beating that it is the
mathematical facts that change your life
it doesn't change your life I mean
there's gonna be some instances where
somebody you know starts when a child is
born and they just load 529s up to the
gills and then they pay for private
school and college tuition out of 529s
and they're actually going to save a
little tax money but the number of
people that don't save for college
period is so high that if we deflect
what should have been college savings to
pay for K through 12 this was a dumb
plan your first goal needs to make sure
your college is funded before you start
worry about private school paying for
that tax-free for two reasons one is
mathematically it doesn't matter and
where you went to your K through 12 as
long as it was safe and you didn't get
shot in the process right as long as
that kind of stuff and where you went to
school there's almost no data that shows
that you're successful because you went
to a private you know K through six
versus a public K through sixth a good
public K through six something safe and
the teachers don't mail it in and that
kind of stuff I mean sometimes you got
trashy school system I get that but
anyway I so just be careful and you
don't let this
tax law redirect your brain because it's
not going to save you much tax money to
run your K through 12 through your 529
and if it causes you to use that money
for that instead of and then they don't
have money for college you screwed up so
your 529 for college is first for two
reasons I hope that makes sense to you
so that's a good question though I'm
glad it came up and the big thing that
happened here the reason I say it's just
just you know chest beating is it's all
of this school choice argument the
political argument on that and you know
you should be able to do it with your
money what you want to do with it I
completely agree with all of that but
mathematically does this change
directions for you it doesn't move the
needle regardless of your politics it's
really not going to change 99 percent of
people that go to private schools life
the number of dollars actually saved
here is a very minimal versus saving 18
years for college you might really save
30 or 40 grand in taxes by using a 529
you're not going to save that much on K
through 12 number one you're not gonna
pay as much probably and number two you
got a fun college first so you gotta
have a lot of money start funding both
of these and I honestly would keep a
separate 529 if you're going to do K
through 12 keep it separate from your
529 for college don't don't mix them and
that way you don't accidentally spend
your college money so your kid can go to
the high school with their little
friends you know which is how people
make decisions on this stupid stuff too
often all our friends go there and all
the sudden you're broke so you just
really have to think you have to think